after we drop off the runners insurance
forms we need to stop by the grocery
store and then we need to sign a suicide
pact because our lives are meaningless
babe we are not boring people would
boring people get renters insurance even
though it's not legally required where
are we i have never once been to this
part of pawnee it's the creepy warehouse
district
it's mostly just raccoons and old car
batteries
whoa hang on pull over
look at that
this place is amazing
let's go in
it says here there are 12 closets three
bomb shelters
five dumb waders
two and three-eighths baths no kitchens
it's a fairly standard layout cool is
that a staircase in nowhere yes it is
good eye
what was this place remember the pony
dollhead factory this was a dollhead
factory no this was a holding cell for
people who went insane on the assembly
line
what's behind this door
a fire pole so this place has had zero
offers people seem to be scared off
on account of it being haunted
and disgusting
after 47 years living here
i decided to move to orlando to be
closer to disney world
we are responsible adults you know what
that means you know we have money and we
are going to buy the
out of this house seriously yes who
needs rental insurance we're gonna live
here
you